hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast scaling cell therapy
manufacturing presented by Jim Beltzer
PhD we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by Tomo BCT true mo
BCT is a global leader in blood
component therapeutic a phoresis and
cellular technologies it is the only
company with unique combination of a
phoresis collections manual and
automated whole blood processing and
pathogen reduction technologies to room
OB CT believes in the potential of blood
to do even more for patients than it
does today
this belief inspires the company's
innovation and strengthens its
collaboration with customers to learn
more about terminal BCT please visit
[Music]
www.opm.gov/life herbs and I'm your
moderator for today's event this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce dr. belt Sura
prior to joining the cell processing
team at Tarun Moby CT dr. belt who
served as lead scientist for the Rd of
Corning synthamax a synthetic growth
surface for the culture of human
embryonic stem cells at Corning Life
Sciences he was a co-founder of red
corporation and was a key player in the
industrialization of several technology
platforms including phage display and
yeast two-hybrid he has more than 20
years
industrial research and development
experience in a broad range of
disciplines please join me in welcoming
dr. belt sir I will now turn the
presentation over to him
today I'd like to present three case
studies in cell therapy manufacturing t
cell expansion case study viral vector
production case study and finally
producing a 10 quantum system watch
before I get to that I would like to
introduce you to the quantum cell
expansion system the quantum is a novel
hollow fiber bioreactor system that is
closed uses continuous perfusion and as
a single use system it's primarily
designed for adherence cells but we also
have some results growing Suspension
cells in the quantum we have automated
all of the necessary steps for
traditional cell culture and we have
extremely good control over the gas
exchange and the temperature in the
quantum this is the single use part this
is the quantum disposable and you can
see the bioreactor on the right and then
the tubing organizer is how the plumbing
interacts with the pumps and valves on
the quantum system and then to the left
of the screen you can see a couple of
the bags that are attached to harvest
bag and the waste bag so here we have
the quantum system with that disposable
mounted so you can see the hollow fiber
bioreactor in the middle of your screen
you can see the four pumps that control
the fluid input to the system and the
circulation of the fluid in the system
also on the Left we have the gas Inlet
and the gas transfer module which is
responsible for all of the gas exchange
that takes place in the quantum system
so where the rubber hits the road is the
hollow fiber bioreactor it's composed of
about 11,500 semipermeable hollow fibers
and you can think of those as very small
straws
the equivalent surface area is about 120
T 175 flaps and the cells grow on the
inside of those hollow fibers as shown
in the micrograph that's on the top
right of the screen so there are
basically two different fluid paths
within the hollow fiber bioreactor the
icy loop which runs down the center of
those straws of the hollow fiber and
basically passes straight from left to
right through the center of the
bioreactor and then there's the extra
capillary loop and you can see the inlet
and outlet of that sticking up on the
top of the bioreactor
and that's basically the bath water that
fills the space that surrounds these
hollow fibers and so there we can
achieve perfusion feeding of the selves
we can use both of these loops to our
advantage
so I show here a hydraulic layout system
for the quantum with the icy loop and
the EC loop shown in red and blue and
the hollow fiber bioreactor shown in the
middle so these controls of inlet and
circulation pumps will become very
important so with the door closed the
bioreactor is now an incubator in fact
we call it a cleanroom in a box all of
the controls are accomplished through
the automated touch screen on the front
of the machine you can see running
across the top the inlets and outlets
are described and that's one thing the
quantum is not smart enough to know
which bag you've attached to which Inlet
line so you have to call that out you
also have control of the various Inlet
pumps on the yellow or for the icy side
and in the blue or for the EC side and
you can see the bioreactor in the middle
of your screen
now our engineers have gone to a lot of
trouble to describe a number of
predefined tasks and multi-step tasks so
they're either single step or multi step
these describe to the best of our
ability all the necessary tasks that you
need to perform to culture cells in the
bioreactor but the most important part
of this entire slide is the purple
button that sits above each task
description and that's the modify button
so all of these tasks are modifiable to
meet your fill culture needs in fact you
can create custom tasks and link them
together
to describe even as much as your entire
run in a single custom step we track the
growth of our cells by sampling media
most commonly from the EC port there's a
lower lock port that's shown on the left
but if you need to get a sample of the
contents of the IC coil right so that's
the IC loop that the cells are growing
on in that loop you can weld off a
portion of the sample coil as shown in
the right before I go into the case
studies I'd like to introduce a cart T
cell therapy
manufacturing that's in development at
room o so the basic process is in a
previous product is can be purified into
lymphocytes and then those lymphocytes
are either gene modified and then
activated and expanded finally the
expanded cells are concentrated and
washed and eventually infused into the
patients this can be accomplished using
trullo devices so the Spector opt you
can do you a phoresis product and
lymphocytes can be purified using the
Eleuthera cell separation system so I'd
like to concentrate on two aspects of
this process that utilize the quantum
system
the first is activation and expansion of
t-cells in the in the quantum system and
the second is the production of viral
vectors using the quantum system as well
so let's start with t-cell expansion in
the quantum system so this is our basic
cell expansion of t-cells in the quantum
system and we typically start out with
2.5 mils of a leukapheresis product or
25 mils of a looot reiated product and
you can get those either from the
apheresis or from the lucra machine we
loaded 100 million lymphocyte into the
Machine approximately two hundred and
twenty eight million excuse me of those
cells were CB 3 plus key cells those
cells were activated with CD 3 cd28
dynabeads
in a two-to-one ratio of cells to be and
then fed by continuous perfusion so
that's on the zero on day 3 6 & 9 we
introduce a bolus of il-2 and aisle 7 as
you can see on the timeline and there's
a minimal amount of circulation in the I
feed loop where the cells are of 1 mil
per minute so that's really quite slow
and our gas exchange is taken care of by
the circulating the EC loop at a hundred
mils per minute that's also clearing out
any waste products that may have been
produced by the expansion of themselves
after day six we do flip the bioreactor
once a day just to break apart the
clumps finally on day 12 we harvest the
cells and we were able to harvest after
a 12 day expansion about 15 billion T
cells
greater than 5
one hundredfold extension in 12 days and
in a low harvest volume of 0.5 to 1
litre now I've shown this same data in a
different format here so you can see on
day zero we started out with 28 million
CD 3 plus T cells and then in the blue
bar in the last column we end up with 15
billion CD 3 plus T cells also of
interest is that we get a selective
enrichment of the cd8 cells that shows
up quite nicely in day 9 and day 12 if
we look at the flow results you can see
that we end up with a 99% pure T cell
population and that's also a
preferential expansion of our cd8 cells
as I mentioned before coming up to about
69% in the final product there is a
significant drop in the PD 1 expression
and our T cells are expressing il-2 and
interferon gamma the activation markers
so just in summary then we had over a
five hundred fold expansion of 2 e + pd
3 + T cells over 12 days
no pre-processing a closed system
automated reduces labor it can be used
in a controlled space perfusion fed and
we use a low amount of media in the
process and we have a low volume for our
harvest moving on to viral vector
production in the quantum system so many
of you are familiar with growing
incubators full of flasks or sell stocks
or roller bottles in order to collect
your viral vector supernatant and I've
heard stories of up to 16 10 stacks
going into a single prep so
this is a labor-intensive process many
open steps there's a clean room is
required because you've got high
concentration of virus large volumes of
vector and it's very contamination prone
there are two types of virus expression
they're stable and transient expression
of viral vectors stable trench section
of retro viral vectors is usually done
using a packaging cell line and your
gene of interest is introduced into a
packaging cell for those purposes
transient expression on the other hand
involves introducing all of the genes
required to produce the virus including
the envelope the gag and the paul-jean
so you would introduce a mixture of four
plasmids into the transient transfection
mix both the packaging cell line in the
transient expression systems have their
pros and cons so the packaging cell line
is obviously very convenient and allows
for stable expression for weeks but that
initial construction of the cell line
can be difficult transient expression on
the other hand is stable for 40 to 72
hours and it is fast and achieves
comparable titers the cons it's batch to
batch variability and difficult to scale
both of these protocols have been used
on the quantum system here's a cartoon
of our transient expression experiments
to produce lentiviral vectors in the
quantum and this was done in
collaboration with Gerhart Bauer's lab
at
Davis for Gen Medicine Center so the
first is to load your HK 293 t-cell if
you're in a hurry and you want to start
the next day then you would load up at
least a billion cells into the
bioreactor if you wish to let the cells
expand first in the bioreactor you can
load fewer cells and allow them to
expand so cells are loaded and allowed
to attach to the bioreactor for 15 hours
or overnight and then when the
population of cells has filled the
bioreactor to approximately 1 to 1.5
billion cells then you can begin your
transfection and so that's day one of
the process so the transfection you add
the four plasmid as I spoke just spoke
about for the transient expression of
lentivirus in calcium phosphate and you
allow the transaction to proceed for 15
hours in the quantum and then at the end
of that 15 hours you wash out and do an
induction for another 9 hours so at the
end of that time we want to collect the
virus this is on day four and we wanted
to be able to concentrate the virus
afterwards so there was a switch to
serum free media and we then proceeded
to feed the cells for 40 hours during
that time we continuously collected the
viral vector in the supernatant or the
conditioned media that passed over the
cells on day 5 we harvested the cells we
got back our 1 to 2.5 billion 2 9 3 T
cells we were able to titer and
concentrate the virus particles and
determine the MLI and the t use per mil
so we've shown that the quantum system
can be used to produce retroviral and
Lenti viral vectors it's automated it's
capable of achieving both stable and
transient extraction systems it's a
closed system
the vector concentration is equal to
what we see in flat space systems and
using engineering controls we can
control the volume of the vector
containing supernatant and in the next
slide I show the hydraulic system layout
again to show you how important that is
in concentrating and decreasing the
volume of our virus containing
supernatant so basically that's achieved
by harvesting the IC loop so you can see
in the diagram that we harvest the IC
loop into a separate bag from the EC
loop where we accomplish the feeding of
the cells and so in summary the results
of our viral vector production in the
quantum for the lentivirus we got about
2 times 10 to the 8th viral particles
per mil which was a similar yield to
what's normally obtained in the cell
stack
likewise scanner retrovirus gave similar
results at youth as to what they had
been getting in their plastic base
system and there will be references for
both of these results at the end of the
talk and moving on to the allergenic
model which is a case study in scaling
out the quantum system from one machine
to ten machines so this case study was a
collaboration between a thesis and its
European subsidiary Regenesis and the
contract manufacturing organization of
master cell so the object was to
transfer the process of some growing
maps fees in the quantum to scale that
process out from one machine to ten
machines to create a larger lot size and
then finally to see if there are any
efficiencies that could be gained and
cutting straight to the chase we found
that there was a forty percent cost a
forty percent reduction in the cost of
goods producing cells in this way so in
the first slide we show the technology
transfer a time line through two
scale-out so the first few weeks were
spent simply learning how to run the
quantum and then another six weeks were
used for process optimization most of
this work was on downstream processing
of the cell product and finally the ten
quantum runs were done in the scale-out
so this is a comparison of running a
single quantum system here in the box on
the bottom it tells you how many people
are required so you can see on day one
we take two operators to run the quantum
system that's mostly to prepare the
cells and the quantum for loading with
the ten quantum system you see it the
box at the top that two operators are
also required in day zero and day one or
day minus one and day zero but basically
the intermediate steps can be handled by
a single operator and as I said before
the harvest day is the most difficult
and here we needed more help so finally
if you look at the product that we got
you can see that the flow cytometry
profiles from the comparing the quantum
produced cells to the cell stacks
produce cells are equal and saying the
same is true for the protein secretion
so you can see that we were able to
develop a process that can yield
consistent cell qualify quality and
yield and can simplify the progression
from learning to production and
importantly there's a 40% cost reduction
in cost of goods and we were able to
produce large lots of cells so here are
the references for the lentiviral the
retroviral and finally the scale out of
the quantum cell expansion system thank
you very much
Thank You dr. Zeltzer for that
informative presentation it is time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask dr. belt sir please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on your screen and click on the
send button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is can you
control the shear stress and the quantum
for the growth of endothelial cells
thanks for that question first of all
there's very little shear stress in the
quantum system that's pure physics that
you've got a quarter inch Inlet line
going into the icy loop and a two inch
in diameter bioreactor there's very
little shear that happens having said
that though we can control the flow rate
of the media through the icy loop with
our pumps and if needed we can even feed
across the membrane without creating
shear stress how can I monitor the
growth of the cells in the quantum so
you can monitor the growth in the in the
quantum by taking a sample from the EEC
sample port so that's a lunar lock port
that is sterile so there's a point two
micron filter behind it we recommend
that you monitor the lactate production
and glucose consumption and typically
those measurements are done once every
24 hours has the quant have been used to
culture IPS cells yes the quantum has
been used to successfully expand IPS
cells we haven't done differentiation of
IPS cells yet in the quantum but that's
ongoing in fact a recent experiments
have shown that the quantum can
significantly reduce the media required
to expand IPS cells what is the media
perfusion rate in the quantum well the
media perfusion rate typically starts
out at zero or very low so it's at what
point one mil per minute
in the beginning stages of a typical
expansion and it may go as high as one
point six mils per minute at the end of
the typical MSC expansion for viral
vectors and and other applications we
may have to go higher as the cell
densities increase within the quantum so
for the viral vector case we are running
up around 2.5 million it is there a
reason for switching to serum free media
for viral vector production ah yes so
that's a good question if you produce
your viral vectors in serum containing
media it complicates the concentration
of that virus product after you have
finished your run
so the serum proteins would quickly clog
the membrane concentrators that are
typically used to concentrate viral
vectors how are the dynabeads loaded
into the system for T cell expansions
very simple we basically mix the
dynabeads with the cells in a cell inlet
bag prior prior loading themself into
the bioreactor and as I mentioned yeah
the ratio is 2 to 1 what kind of media
is used for T cell expansions today we
tried both text max and rpm I plus 2
percent human AV serum and right now we
get the best results with our PMI but we
plan to test more media in the future so
stay tuned we're almost out of time so
this will have to be our last question
how our suspension cells kept in the
hollow fiber bioreactor so our pumps the
circulation pumps in the quantum expect
cell expansion system can be reversed so
we can run those pumps in such a fashion
as to push any cells that may have
gotten out into the rest of the ICU loop
back into the bioreactor so again we
just use our circulation pumps I would
like to once again thank
Beltzer for his presentation do you have
any final comments I just want to thank
everybody and if you have any questions
further to this please contact me at my
email that should be on the last slide
of the presentation well thank you once
again I would also like to thank our
sponsor to room o BCT for making today's
educational webcast possible this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits and before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through November 31st 2017 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye
you